welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation titled
the long journey toward developing a
biomarker panel
for lung cancer screening it's my
pleasure to introduce to you
dr sam anash the director of red and
charlene
mccombs institute for the early
detection and treatment of cancer
at the university of texas md anderson
cancer center in houston texas
dr hanash was recruited to md anderson
cancer center in 2011
to lead the red and charlene mccombs
institute for cancer early detection and
treatment
he was previously program head of
molecular diagnosis
at the fred hutchinson cancer research
center
dr kanash interest and expertise are in
the field of cancer diagnostics and the
development of blood-based
cancer biomarkers for risk assessment
and cancer early detection he is the
inaugural
president of the international human
prodom
organization dedicated to the study of
the human proteome and the founder of
the u.s
human proteome organization for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the tab at the top
of your screen if you have any questions
that you want arise during the
presentation simply type them into the q
in a box on the right
and dr anash will answer questions
following the presentation
please join me now in welcoming dr sam
nash
i will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir
well i appreciate the introduction and
the opportunity to share with you
this long journey toward developing a
biomarker panel
for lung cancer screening this
journey started out when i was in
seattle at the fred hutchinson cancer
center
and it has accentuated and
when i moved from seattle to houston
to be the director of the red and
charlene mccombs institute
for the early detection and treatment of
cancer this is an institute that
regroups several centers
adam d anderson including the center for
global cancer early
detection
for disclosure i'm receiving support for
this program
from abbott and at the same time we have
filed ip and done some licensing for
markers
for uh lung cancer screening
you may ask there's already screening
going on
for lung cancer at the present time
based on low dose ct
so why do we need markers
for screening well the answer is on this
slide here
at the present time based on the u.s
preventive services task force
recommendations for low dose ct you have
to be a smoker that has smoked 30 pack
years
and um that are currently smoking or
quit within the past 15 years to be
eligible for low dose ct
on the other hand at the present time
most
subjects destined to be diagnosed
and die of lung cancer do not meet those
screening criteria
and so the question becomes what do we
do
for those subjects that are currently
not eligible
for ct screening and so
the answer would be that
why not consider a blood test
that we would do for a smoker
that would determine the risk of having
lung cancer
so they may not be 30 back year smokers
they could be 10
pack year smokers or they could be 30
pack year smokers that quit more than 15
years
if their blood test turns out to be
positive
indicating a risk for lung cancer just
as high
as the 30-pack year smoker then
why not then have that blood test
available
we go to the doctor for checkup we get
our cholesterol
checked and we take that for granted
these days and so
if somebody is a smoker and there's a
blood test that determines their risk
then why not use that as a way to
improve
basically screening for lung cancer and
reduced
mortality which is substantial as we
know
lung cancer is the number one cancer
killer worldwide
um and so there has been concern
for quite some time now about the
restrictive nature
of the u.s preventive services task
force recommendation of 30 pack years
and quitting less than 15 years and so
as a result of the concerns and some
recent modeling that has been done
then the u.s preventive services task
force
is now considering considering
recommending reducing the pac-year
requirement to 20 back years and so if
this is indeed is implemented then
of course more subjects destined to be
diagnosed
with lung cancer and die of lung cancer
would have been
screened and their cancer detected at
an early stage and so
with those new recommendations
in mind one would think
that okay we have solved that problem
still
even with reducing the pack years down
to 20
there's still the issue of subjects who
did not even smoke 20 back years or
maybe even did not smoke at all
then could be destined to be diagnosed
with lung cancer
and the diagnosis would be an advanced
stage
and so there's still a lot of merit for
developing a blood test that allows
a subject's risk for lung cancer to be
assessed now we also have to keep in
mind
that not every subject who would be
eligible for screening with
low dose ct is actually getting screened
with low dose ct the uptake has been
very very low and
there are a lot of reasons for that you
need to make an appointment to get a ct
you need to have uh basically an imaging
test
that maybe or may not be reimbursed
and at the same time one has to give
consideration to the fact that
well okay you got your first ct and it
was negative then what would you do next
well
it's not very clear at the present time
but maybe you would be getting your ct
every year and so you could imagine
after 20 or 30 years that you would have
had a lot of cts
and sort of like the joke around is that
you're going to increase somebody's risk
on account of being exposed to ct
although that increa incremental risk is
really
very modest but nevertheless there's
uh quite a justification
for wanting to have a blood test to aid
in ct
screening now
if you look at it from that perspective
then
you could have your blood test done
before you do a ct
on the other hand a blood test could be
a companion to ct
because we know the limitations of ct
there's
over diagnosis there are not joules that
are seen by ct
that may or may not turn out to be
cancer and
at the same time there are cases where
act
is done and before they are due for the
next ct a year later
they are diagnosed with lung cancer and
lo and behold they are not only
diagnosed with lung cancer they are
diagnosed with advanced
lung cancer and so having a blood test
that complements ct either prior to ct
or in conjunction with ct would be
appealing
so this is kind of like the positive
speech about the a blood test
that would aid in screening for lung
cancer
and reducing mortality now here's the
problem so if you go to pubmed and ask
well has anyone
worked on biomarkers for lung cancer are
there any publications there
and when i did that as i was preparing
my talk here
the number of publications related to
lung cancer and biomarkers turned out to
be 35
452 publications
and you would say oh my god i mean
there's so much work that has been done
and yet there is no biomarker panel
available today
that aids in screening for lung cancer
and so you may say well
biomarkers could have all kinds of
indications in relation to lung cancer
maybe not screening
and so can we be a little bit more
specific so okay well let's do a pubmed
search of lung cancer screening and
biomarkers
and that number goes down to thirteen
thousand six hundred and fifty four
wow now okay let's be
even more specific and let's say lung
cancer screening
and blood based biomarkers that number
still
is as high as more than 4 000
papers talking about blood biomarkers
and lung cancer screening
four thousand eight hundred and thirty
so if you want
to start in this area let's say that you
are a diagnostics company or you're
thinking about well we need a
sort of a blood test for lung cancer
let's look at what the opportunities
are and if the first thing that you do
is to do a pubmed search and come up
with 4
830 publications you would say
whoa if all kinds of people
in companies and academia or what have
you
all over the world have been working on
lung cancer screening but biomarkers
came up with those
that's such an astounding number of
papers and still nothing is
out there then there must be
a problem and so
what could that problem be
here's on the next slide this is the
problem
if you sit down with a pencil and piece
of paper and they ask yourself
what could there be in the blood that
could
inform about lung cancer
and well then the answer to that
is pretty straightforward you could be
looking
at anyone of at least a dozen
different types of markers molecules and
what have you
in the blood and so those could be
circulating tumor cells those could be
micro particles like exosomes coming out
of tumors
they could be proteins they could be
metabolized they could be dna
and dna could be all kinds of different
groupings of dna it could be mutations
it could be dna methylation
it could be nucleic acid micrornas or
even rna
and you say wow how are we going to
figure out
what works and what does not work and so
all of this
is really my introduction
to how at md anderson we approached
our search for biomarkers
that will aid in lung cancer screening
and so we decided that we are going to
go through
every paper that has been published
about
lung cancer lung cancer screening
blood-based biomarkers and try to see
which ones in there have
some legitimate finding that could be
relevant
to screening if there are
several papers that have worked at the
same type
of biomarker let's say micro rna
then we would ask okay well you have a
group in italy a group in spain a group
in cleveland or whatever
that have worked on micro rna for lung
cancer did they find something in common
and most of the time
remarkably the answer is no there are
so many different studies that have been
done and each one going in a different
direction and not finding the same thing
and so we decided that we are going to
kind of sift through
triage all of those publications and
look at what would be
promising biomarkers because the design
of the study is relevant
most of the time what you see is people
look at advanced stage cancer they found
something interesting
and they sort of assumed that it could
be relevant to the detection of very
early stage
cancer when the subjects are
asymptomatic and the answer is that if
you go through that route
you are going to be quite disappointed
and so we applied a triage mechanism
whereby we would look at
any which large number any one of a
large number
of biomarker types and biomarkers
and see what we could come up with by
way
of markers that pass the initial
kind of sort of triage beyond actually
just triaging the paper
and the uh candidates that were
described in that paper
and so that's the approach that we have
followed
and so in order to do that and if your
application
is screening for lung cancer again like
i mentioned earlier it
is not very informative to work
with blood that was collected at the
time of diagnosis
from subjects with advanced stage cancer
and so what is the alternative to that
well the alternative as is shown on this
slide
is working with blood that was collected
from newly diagnosed early stage
subjects and more importantly
work with blood that was collected at a
time
the subject did not know that they were
going to be diagnosed with lung cancer
and this is through population studies
cohorts epidemiology
type of studies that have been done
whereby
ten thousand twenty thousand whatever
thousand number of subjects
have been uh basically enrolled in the
study
and blood was collected at baseline and
so if you have
ten thousand subjects have been uh
enrolled in a study and their blood was
collected
at baseline some of those are destined
to be diagnosed with this or that cancer
and then you could go back to their
blood at the time they were asymptomatic
and ask okay this potential biomarker
does it validate
in this type of a setting and if it
validates you keep it on the list if it
doesn't validate you take it out
so this is a very substantial
undertaking that we have done
for example the initial work that we did
in addition to newly diagnosed subjects
with early-stage lung cancer
we worked with the women's health
initiative and this is a cohort of 160
000 women that we had access to blood
from women that later were diagnosed
with lung cancer
we worked with the caret cohort which is
a cohort of some 16 000 subjects
at risk for lung cancer and that kind of
smoking blood was collected at baseline
and then we were able to look at blood
within a year of diagnosis of lung
cancer
and ask what could we find in there and
can we validate our finding
in a different cohort type of thing and
so
we relied on particular cohort
to build a panel of biomarkers
and then once we have built that panel
of biomarkers
we relied on additional cohort to
validate
that panel and so we went from newly
diagnosed early stage
uh women's health initiative cohort the
care cohort
we built a particular panel that was the
intent
and then we validated in a in two
european cohorts the number
approximately half a million subjects
that blood was collected at baseline
and we used those blood from subjects
that later were diagnosed with lung
cancer
to validate a panel that we had already
established
so that got us a step further and now
where we are at
is we want to go from a research setting
into a setting where the assays
are clinical grade assays so we would do
the ultimate validation in blood that
was collected
either through yet an additional cohort
the prostate lung colon ovarian
nci cohort where blood was collected at
baseline
and on a regular basis and at md
anderson we launched a
lung cancer screening cohort that we
for subjects that come in for screening
for lung cancer
and we have blood that has been
collected from well over
500 blood collections from those
subjects
and some of them obviously were
diagnosed with lung cancer on account of
ct screening
and we could use those blood tests to
validate the marker
yet another validation
and so this is the approach that we have
followed now i'll have to go back
a few years back to maybe
2000 2013 2014
when we asked ourselves can we really
come up with markers that could be
valid before subjects are diagnosed with
lung cancer
at the time they were asymptomatic and
so we did a
this was a proteomics mass spectrometry
study
whereby we looked at blood from
mouse models of lung cancer and the
advantage of those emotional models of
lung cancer
is that you can collect blood before you
turn on the cancer-causing gene
and then you can sequentially collect
blood
and ask yourself using an advanced
proteomics mass spectrometry platform
can we see
changes in the blood early on with tumor
development
and we would do a similar sort of
analysis of blood collected from human
subjects
and then look at what is common
both to mouse blood and to human blood
and so lo and behold we found a lot of
molecules proteins in the blood that go
up
with tumor development in humans and the
mouse
and those are shown in
a very very fine font here
in red for those that go up
and in green for those proteins that go
down and so there's a collection of
proteins in the blood that went up with
tumor development
and so statistics showed that those
uh a lot of those proteins were
associated with tumor development
but the question is okay well statistics
is interesting but it doesn't give you
a clinic a clue as to biology but
we had a smart md phd post doc working
on this project
and he did a lot of searches for those
things that go up in the blood
trying to figure out why did they go up
and lo and behold
it turned out that a lot of those
features protein features on the blood
that go up
are regulated by nkx 2.1
and what is nkx 2.1 it's a
proto-oncogene
that has been linked to the development
of lung cancer at
early stages so that was super exciting
for us and this came out in cancer cell
and made the cover and that
basically yes there is a prospect of
being able
to develop a blood test that could pick
up cancer
early on before onset of symptoms so we
were very excited about this at the time
and it was really the justification of
not simply wanting to pursue
the type of study that we had done and
validated
but wanting to do all out and look at
any potential biomarker in an unbiased
fashion
and see what holds up the best in terms
of being
promising for lung cancer screening
and so when we did that initial study
and the one that came out in cancer cell
that i showed
you on the previous slide what was
interesting is one of the markers that
was being turned on
by nkx 2.1 was surfactant b
and so we all know about surfactant as a
physiologic
uh factor in the blood uh uh
related to lung physiology
and so when we looked at our data more
precisely
it turned out that actually it wasn't
the mature form of surfactant b
it was an immature form of surfactant b
that is being turned on
through nkx 2.1 early on during tumor
development
and what you see on this slide is when
we compare the performance
of surf mature surfactant b
which is the curve in black
with the performance of the pro
surfactant b which is the curve in
red you see that in fact for surfactant
b is more informative the area under the
curve for
in red for poor surfactant b is superior
to the one in black and the difference
as
a p-value that was significant
and so we decided to make an essay for
personal fact and b
that became ultimately our anchor
sort of marker for anything else that we
wanted to test
that could have relevance for lung
cancer
screening so
is there evidence that even though you
have a good auc curve
well we know that smoking represents
a major risk factor for lung cancer so
we looked at the pan-canadian lung
cancer screening core
where subjects could subjects the risk
could be defined based on smoking and we
asked
well would adding just this one marker
improve our ability to assess risk
compared to the smoking model
and what you see here in red is the
smoking model
risk related to the smoking model and
what you see in the in
blue is the base basic smoking model to
which we have added this one marker pro
surfactant b
and what you can see is there's a
significant increment
in assessing risk in the pan canadian
screening core
this is a paper that came out in jco in
2015
and the difference between the
performance of the basic screening model
the smoking model and the addition of
one marker
difference in auc at the p-value point
zero zero
zero two so this was really exciting for
us
and contributed to our conviction that
we will be able to come up with a marker
panel
that determines somebody's risk and the
need to be screened by ct
for lung cancer so with the approach
surfactant b
you could say well could there be a
subset of subjects
that contributed to the performance and
and maybe it was men more than women it
was subjects that were later diagnosed
with
adeno as opposed to squamous as opposed
to small cell
and when we looked at the data and the
canadian screening you cannot see the
detail here but i can
tell you that any which way we looked at
the subjects
that were screened whether in relation
to
what was their diagnosis exactly or age
or sex or what have you
smoking history then the uh pro
surfactant be
performed with a very significant
p-value which added to the conviction
that this could be a good marker to be
included
in a screening biomarker panel
so what was astounding at the time we
did the analysis
of the pan canadian screening data
was there were 17 subjects
that had the negative ct and baseline
and before they were due for the next ct
were diagnosed with lung cancer and like
i mentioned earlier
they were diagnosed with advanced stage
lung cancer and so we were very eager to
see how that one marker
per surfactant be performed in that
group and so there are four groupings
here
that you see on the slide in terms of
the values for burst surfactant b
on the left side was subjects who had an
abnormal ct that turned out not to be
lung cancer
the next is subjects with incident lung
cancer that had the negative ct those 17
subjects
and then you have subjects that were
diagnosed with lung cancer at the time
the ct was done
and subjects that were normal those 17
subjects that had a negative ct
had the highest value of per surfactant
b
than at baseline when the ct was
negative
which was incredibly it's like it still
gives me goosebumps that a blood marker
can signal the presence of cancer in
this fashion for those subjects better
than ct itself
so how were we going to look through
umpteen types of biomarkers to come up
with a panel
and so like i mentioned earlier with a
lot of data that we generated for person
factor and b
this became our anchor marker and the
next marker that seems to be promising
would be
added as the next anchor marker type of
thing but it was very important that the
assay system
would be one that can give you good
analytical reproducibility
so that you don't have asthma related
issues
and then at the end we thought that when
we do all of this exercise which was
pretty daunting and substantial we're
going to come up with the best marker
combination
and that's what we're going to go with
and run with
so like i said there are all kinds of
different types
of potential biomarkers one platform
that we have utilized
is metabolomics we asked well could
there be metabolites in the blood
that could be relevant to assessing
somebody's ears for lung cancer
and one metabolite that stood out in our
initial discovery and validation work
was a polyamine distilled spermine that
gave a very good
area under the curve when you look at
subjects
whose blood was collected before a
diagnosis of lung cancer
and then the next thing that we did
obviously was to see okay well this
curve kind of looks a little bit like
per surfactant b
do they complement each other or simply
basically have no additive value
and indeed when we looked at
the for the same subjects that had poor
surfactant b
and d a s assay and looked at the
contribution
of either one and the two together then
it became very clear
that the combination of
uh polyamine gas and per surfactant b
gave an improved sensitivity
at a very high specificity as you can
see the red curve on the left
and again that has associated with a
good p-value
and that came up as it came out as a
follow-up paper
in jco in 2015. so we thought okay well
we have two markers already
that complement each other let's keep
going
and so there were a lot of publications
about micro rnas
and we selected out of those those types
of publications
were the same a micro rna was identified
in more than one paper
and where they looked at early stage
lung cancer
and so we pulled out all of those micro
rnas and we assate them
and they ask well could microrna make a
contribution here
and the answer is yes and so the
micrornas that validated on their own
when we added them to the other markers
that we already have
and by that time we had quite a cocktail
of biomarkers
what you can see here on the curve is
pro surfactant b
distills per mean and adding to a two
micro rnas
and what sort of performance do we get
we get a significant performance
now we were very excited about this
and we started talking to our colleagues
who are perhaps more in the entrenched
in the clinic
in the clinical chemistry lab than we
were and we told them well what do you
think a combination of metabolites a
protein and a micro rna
as a way to screen for lung cancer
and they said boy that is going to be
very complicated you're talking about
three different platform and metabolic
how are you going to
estate that you're going micro rna how
are you going to answer that protein how
are you going to answer that
this is kind of almost like a loser
proposition
you want to include so many different
things if you think that you're going to
have
a test that will be implemented among
millions of subjects that's going to be
problematic
and so we thought hmm what are we going
to do i mean if it's not practical
to have any which combination of markers
what are we going to do
well we thought our lead
biomarker that we discovered early on
was a protein
why don't we look to see if there are
any other proteins
that are supported by the literature
that could be good marker to screen for
lung cancer
and as we all know there are quite a few
markers out there that are being used
clinically
for subjects who are diagnosed with lung
cancer so we had those on the list and
we had many others that looked promising
from the literature
and we tested each one of them to see
whether they contribute to our
basically um lead biomarker which is for
surfactant b
and that basically turned out to be
very promising so now what about
dna there's a lot of interest in dna
and like i said it could be dna
methylation it could be mutation what
have you
and so again we looked at dna to see
what it would contribute
and fortunately looking at dna
specifically for mutation
it performed great in advanced stage
but the performance in early stage was
rather
modest and so at that point we decided
that
let's stick to see what we could get out
of the proteins we will come back to dna
and see if it can contribute down
downstream the reason we did that was
adding a dna test to a protein test
will jack up the cost considerably but
we obviously did not give up on
dna it had some performance but we
decided to focus our effort
on proteins and so
we assembled a marker panel of four
proteins
and we decided to test it
this marker panel was developed and
validated in the caret pre-diagnostic
cohort of smokers
at risk for lung cancer cases
i saw average for lung cancer and the
way
we tested it was like i showed on a
previous slide
in a completely independent cohort
from europe consisting of umea samples
and the epic pan-european cohort
uh two studies uh uh that
basically are collaborated at the
international agency for cancer research
provided us with in a blinded
fashion to test our market panel and
the outcome of that blinded validation
using yet another
independent cohort came out in jama
oncology
two years ago and so here is
basically the finding that came out in
gemma oncology
so we looked at blood that was collected
a year
prior to a diagnosis of lung cancer
and looked for the performance of our
marker panel
in determining subjects risk of being
diagnosed with lung cancer compared
with the performance
of a model that was primarily based on
smoking history
so with smoking history you can
determine somebody's risk
and the performance of their uh
basic model is shown in black here
and you see the curve in black and what
you have in red
is the added performance of a four
protein marker panel
that we published in jama oncology then
that included our lead marker pro
surfactant b
and so when you see when you look at
that curve in red
it's much more performing than simply
looking at somebody's smoking history
number one and when you look at the
criteria being used
today for screening if you were to have
your blood test you
have much greater sensitivity at the
same specificity this is looking at the
intersection
of the horizontal and the vertical line
so either the same specificity as
the uspstf criteria we get
greater sensitivity or add the
sensitivity
of the usps criteria pstf criteria we
get greater
specificity so that was incredibly
exciting
for us and so what are we doing at the
present time going back to the schema
for validation that
we wanted to implement now almost eight
years ago where we are at today is
basically wanting to validate validate
our four marker panel using a clinical
grade
assay and we are applying this in a
blinded fashion
to samples that we received from the nci
that were part of the prostate long
colon ovarian cohord
and so we're doing this in the most
rigorous way possible
using a clinical grade assay
so over the multiple
validation studies that we have done of
this four marker panel
whether it's carrot epic umea
and the early data that we have now from
plco
we have robust very reproducible
performance of our
four marker protein panel
which makes us think that indeed this is
quite robust
and it withstood looking at a cohort of
smokers looking at a general population
in europe looking at a screening cohort
that is supported by the nci we got the
same performance
so for us that represents a
major milestone in terms of validation
studies that we have done
and so i
i'm sure you have seen the news media
and the coverage
about well why do we screen for one
cancer at a time
why don't we screen for all cancers with
a blood test
and this way we can save more lives
because other modalities may not be
that effective so adding a blood test
that could screen
for all kinds of cancers could be a good
thing
and so there are two papers that were
published recently
one in the annals of oncology by the
grail group
and the other one that was published in
science
by the thrive group about
basically testing a marker panel
that would have a merit
in detecting multiple cancers and so
the grail marker panel
was based on dna methylation whereas the
thrive
marker panel was based on proteins on
the one hand
protein markers plus looking at
dna mutations and so right there that
tells you that there's
a lot of possibilities for different
types of biomarkers to yield
a potentially valid test and so
uh dr vestava the nci and myself then
were
invited to comment about those two
studies and because there was a lot of
i mean you may call it a type or promise
or hope
a lot of interest in those studies and
so
we basically had
a sort of like an opinion piece about
the merits
of pain cancer sort of screening
and our feeling was yes
eventually that could be great but for
now
it may be a little bit uh
premature because when you look at the
data from thrive
and from grail the subjects
that were found to be positive
they turned out to be more like advanced
stage
subjects as opposed to early stage
subjects so
this is working with cohorts of newly
diagnosed subjects and a lot of cancers
in particular lung cancer were missed in
the prospective cohord that was
part of the studies and so for now we
feel that it may be premature to screen
everybody for all kinds of cancer based
on a blood test
on the other hand there's an opportunity
to screen
subjects at high risk and again
what better cohort to screen
for cancer than heavy duty or
even moderate duty smokers
because they are at high risk for lung
cancer but also average for other
cancers
and so our sort of strategy here is
let's learn to walk before we start
running
let's start seeing what we can do by way
of blood testing
for subjects at high risk and obviously
smokers are not the only subject at high
risk for cancer
for example obese women have an
increased risk to breast cancer and
perhaps other cancers
subjects with inherited familial
this or that type of cancer at risk are
at risk and so
why don't we start with high risk
subjects and see how we can come up
with blood tests and demonstrate our
ability to catch their cancer
early so at this point
basically this is the strategy that we
want to implement at md anderson
and beginning with subjects and risk for
lung cancer and other cancer due to
smoking
but also women who may be at risk for
breast cancer we have launched a
mammography screening cohort to be able
to
develop and improve eventually our
approach to
screening for breast cancer using blood
tests in combination with imaging
modalities
so what is the conclusion from my
presentation today
well i strongly believe that blood-based
biomarkers will play a role in cancer
screening
first through subjects at high risk
identifying them and say okay you are a
tyrist for breast cancer
you are high-risk for pancreatic cancer
or for
lung cancer and that should trigger the
next follow-up which would
logically be an imaging modality
that would be one thing that we have
learned and obviously
blood markers by themselves don't tell
you about
that there is indeed a cancer or the
location of that cancer
we feel the blood biomarkers in
combination with imaging modality
perhaps at the time of screening
would be very useful and that would
reduce the false positives
and false negatives associated with
imaging
and for now pancaster screening
with a blood test perhaps should be
first optimized and
make sure that it works for lung cancer
breast cancer or colon cancer or what
have you
as opposed to picking out only five
percent or ten percent of this or that
cancer
i think we have a little bit of a way uh
to go
so this is a long journey like
the title of my presentation said there
are a lot of people
that have been involved all some within
my group and other collaborators
not only in the us but also in europe
and china
that have been involved in different
studies that we have i cannot
basically acknowledge them individually
they are all on this slide here
but more importantly is the funding
support that we have received for all of
the lung cancer studies that we have
done
to come up with a marker panel for the
different cohorts we have had different
sources of study
but we are really uh very
fortunate and very
sort of humbled by the support that we
got in md anderson through different
types of foundations
we the canary foundation the longevity
foundation the rubrus
family foundation the user cancer
fighters
and very very
supportive by the hill foundation
provided the bulk of funding
that allowed us to do all of this work
and that's the end of my presentation
and thank you very much
and happy to answer questions
thank you dr hanash for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move to the live q a portion
of the presentation
and as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
so let's take a look we already have
some incoming questions
dr hernach what if a biomarker screening
test
is positive and the follow-up imaging
test
is negative what would be done
well that's a very good question
and i gave the example of
the pan canadian screening cohort where
our lead biomarker was
positive before the ct became positive
and before subjects were diagnosed with
lung cancer
and so what we have learned from that
sort of finding or experience
is that indeed the ct could be negative
but a negative ct does not mean that the
subject doesn't have cancer
and so there are two options in that
situation one is
not to wait another year or two years
before you get the follow-up
ct but do uh
repeat the imaging modality much earlier
than that let's say
two months uh after the blood test that
turned out positive
then was done that could be basically
one way of dealing with it another
would be to go back to that ct it may
have been considered negative or maybe
there was a very small nodule that
people thought that the radiologists
thought well
this is unlikely to be cancer but given
that the blood test was positive
then go back and take a second look at
the low dose ct or beyond that go to an
mri or another imaging modality
so i think the uh positive
blood test should uh have an impact
on how the subject is followed
thank you so much dr hanash we have time
for one more question
given differences in subject
characteristics
would markers perform similarly in
different countries
again that's also a good question and so
we have uh launched back
when i moved to md anderson a lung
cancer screening cohort in the united
states
and we also have two sites one in paris
and one in madrid that have collected
blood from subjects
and we have a major collaboration with
the chinese cancer center in beijing
whereby we have recruited more than 6
000
subjects that went through lung cancer
screening and
our preliminary data so far from
different studies that we have done
is that the marker panels at least the
ones that we've
uh assembled are robust enough that
uh it does not matter whether you're
dealing with a particular ethnicity
that the markers would be positive but
that's something that needs to be
obviously validated directly by looking
at
subjects from different communities one
of the issues for example
that a particular community or a
particular country
might have a lot a higher frequency of
particular chronic infections for
example
that may affect
the performance of the marker panel so
those things have to kind of
be done under due diligence
thank you again dr sam hanash and thank
you to our audience for
your outstanding questions we hope you
found today's presentation to be
informative
and insightful this presentation will be
available for on-demand
viewing don't miss on the other valuable
presentations on this agenda
and visit the agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
bye